oh my goodness  oh she comes into the frame  she comes into the frame  yeah oh i know  i know  what you doing  what you doing  what are you doing ladies look at her  look her little butt sticking up  yeah  what's that all about  yeah  you're on tv  she's like what is that thing  what's that thing  oh no pookie i don't know what it is you  wanna play with your mouthy  yeah there's something else you wanna  dip on him  she's like right  come on hey  you're not in the mall to play with  marcin today  you're kind of playing yeah you could  rub on the melody  yeah you kind of want to play with the  mousy  there you go  get down  at this point this button is hilarious  yeah you're just going to chill  you're just gonna chill by mama  okay  oh my goodness  oh my goodness  you're so cute mommy just doesn't know  what to do with herself  you  know i know you can't help it but  i know  that all you have to say  okay